hey youtubers is charlie so I snagged a
whole bunch of your questions for my
telltale games video earlier today I
tried to pick a mixture of book show and
game questions generally you guys all
seem pretty pumped about it like I said
once the game actually drops in December
I'll probably use it for a weekly
giveaway on my video game channel in
addition to the book giveaway here on my
main channel and I totally forgot to
mention it this morning but Syrio Forel
from the show the actor was cast in Star
Wars Episode seven so that's two Game of
Thrones actors because remember
gwendoline christie is also in it i just
did a big update video for it so there
will be a link in the description for
that if you want to learn more about
Star Wars Episode 7 Syrio Forel probably
did get cast as the Jedi though because
you do not cast a water dancer if you do
not want them to dance there's so many
god of death jokes you could make in the
Star Wars universe since jedec can
transcend physical form but on two
questions number one Edward asks how
closely will the game be tied to season
five so the game will be separate from
the show but they probably did consult
each other on the stories just to see
what things the show was going to
include in season 5 the game is designed
so that the story isn't super dependent
on what goes down on the show and the
same is true for the boats they're not
going to make it so that you have to
watch the show to understand the game
and you don't have to buy the game to
understand the show I do expect the game
to be a little bit closer to the show
than the walking dead game is to the
walking dead show but don't expect the
characters in the video game to be
hanging out with the main characters all
the time and remember decisions that you
make early on will affect later
interactions you have so you could turn
the tide of battle based on the options
you make but question number two
vladimir asks will the game be free only
if you win one of my giveaways but
seriously though it's going to be way
cheaper than normal console game in the
united states for example destiny on
xbox is about 60 US dollars The Walking
Dead telltale Game in comparison is only
25 US dollars you can buy a season pass
to get all the future episodes in
addition to the initial game the
episodes are like content patches where
they roll out new story it's an extra
fifteen dollars to get all the episodes
per season the game of thrones again
will pretty much be the exact same
prices of The Walking Dead game like
they want to keep it cheap i'll probably
be buying the steam version just because
it's more convenient for me to play on
my computer
but whichever country you live in
however much the walking dead game is
right now that's basically how much Game
of Thrones is going to cost they haven't
confirmed the number of episodes per
season but I'd expect it to be on par
with walking dead and there were five
episodes during season two of the game
this year on to question number three
space gypsy asks are you implying that
your Jon Snow I'm not sure what you made
this in reference to but I do have the
same birthday as Kit Harington which i
think is kind of funny question number
four Tom Monty asks what date will
season five air in the UK pretty much
the same day that season four premiere
in the US that was april six the first
sunday in april so 2015 would make that
april fifth I know international time
zones make a little bit weird but plan
on it premiering at the same time last
year they might bump it by a week though
forward or backward but question number
five Paul long asks do you think a
spoilery battle in the game will go down
the same way it does in the books so I
omitted the name just in case people
skip the spoiler section for my video
this morning if the game does go that
far it'll depend entirely on the
decisions you make probably remember
it's choose your own adventure so you
could completely derp the big battles or
make all the right choices to make you
win once the game gets closer to release
will probably have a better idea of what
the narrative arc is going to be so then
we'll have a better picture for what
they're going to be doing from the books
of the show I don't think the game will
be exactly like the show or the books
but I think it'll be really close I will
continue to do preview videos for the
video game as we learn new information
though but question number 6 mattis asks
do you think that Oberon poisoned Tywin
before his death no but only because the
mountain was the first person on Oberon
list Talon was on his list he just
wasn't the first person had he lived had
Oberon lived eventually he would have
totally killed Tywin presumably using
his spear in the most painful way
possible just picture Oberyn just
running the spear up from bottom to top
you know sku the idea but number 7 Joe
Byrne asks do you have a favorite book
in the series and could you rank them so
it's been a little while since I've read
book 5 like that's the latest one I read
but I would say that's probably my
favorite right now Dance with Dragons
was the first book that I waited for in
anticipation having
read all the other books like if you
started the series when the first book
was published in 1996 you get to
experience that long wait in the crazy
rush whenever they finally released book
2 then book 3 and so on that's why I
expect that whenever wins a winner is
released the trend will continue and
that'll be my new favorite book but
ranking all the books so far starting
with best to less best I wouldn't say
any of them are bad so I didn't want to
say worst but it's a book 5 before but
one book 2 and book 3 really it's been
so long since I've read most of the
books that a lot of the events and the
earlier ones bleed together in my head I
do have to go back and reference them if
I forget when certain events happen I
will probably end up re reading books
four and five before next year though
before season five just because those
are mostly going to be with the show on
season five draws from that question
number eight Justin wang asks could you
do a room tour video yeah I can't
remember where I said it but I think I
already promised to do a room tour video
right now is just like a bunch of boxes
like I'm standing in a corner right now
and I haven't really unpacked anything
that's why this looks like I'm in limbo
i'm expecting to be done with all that
at least by october so it's not going to
be too long definitely before i hit 500
k subs but i am planning a special thing
that's a little bit different for
whenever that happens so i'll be making
more announcements as that gets closer
but pushing number 9 shame CC asks do
you think that Theon could be azure a
high right now based on the information
we have and all the theories that I've
read I would still say that Daenerys is
a Zorua I but that's just my opinion
she's the closest thing to an avatar of
fire that might totally change based on
what happens during winter winter but
unless things take a dramatic left turn
I already have my ideas about who the
champions of ice and fire are going to
be I did like a whole white Walker
prophecy video where I kind of detail
that out in great detail so I'll add a
link in the description if you guys want
to learn more about that I do think that
Theon is going to continue to be
important or wreak or however you want
to think about him but mostly during
this boiler battle during winds of
winter I talked about that earlier today
so just re-watch the video game video
that I've posted this morning but
question number 10 and last one Kevin
asks is it true that the actor playing
Jack and guards coming back to the show
if so will he play the kindly man so yes
it's totally true that the actor
playing Jack and a guard came back to
the show but because the show is going
to be different from the books it's
possible that they'll change that kindly
man character a little bit if you're a
book reader and it kind of sounds like
you are I think that jackin is really
the alchemist in the kindly man is
someone totally different but the show
does tend to combine book characters a
lot so it's possible Jack and could
become an amalgam of a couple of
different Faceless Men characters for
those that don't know the kindly man is
like a leader inside the Faceless Men
the order that Jack and Hegar belongs to
I already did a big video explaining who
they are and what they might be doing
during season five so i'll add a link in
the description for that too since i
originally planned to do a faith
militant video until this stuff came
along i'll probably make that my next
bonus video be sure to subscribe to get
it they're basically like the
militarized arm of the church of the
seventh so they're probably going to be
featured in season five don't know quite
how yet but congratulations to this
week's giveaway winner Luca Lauren you
win your choice of any of the song of
ice and fire books or the short stories
so I'll message you on your channel for
details the next round of the giveaway
just like normal will start whenever I
post my next bonus video right now click
here to learn all about the Faceless Men
and click here to learn all about the
video game if you didn't see that video
this morning thank you so much for
watching I'll see you guys tonight high
fives
you